Zakk Wylde just walked in he's giving
Jim a hug what's going on man how are
you doing you smell really good what
kind of Cologne is that new black label
septic tank and you look guy you look
thin is that on purpose
um now it's just balancing out White
Castle and Jenny Craig okay yeah so you
try to lose weight or not
anyways know what else is shaking man
I'm good I'm really good but you look
really thinner than I've ever seen you
look before I feel I feel like a sexy
rock mutant boy that's what you are a
sexy rock mutant boy did you get to a
point like you let it out for a while
you had some health issues and now you
seem like you're doing a lot better did
you get to a point we got like a wake-up
call like [ __ ] man I got to stop what
I'm doing
no never no no I just cuz people would
always like this oh you don't drink
anymore I go now and I go good for you I
go no bad bad for me do you miss it no
no I mean like you know I got buddies at
ah well you know we all do you know
y'all got your friends that are just
like I'm like Jim did you see Tom he
said he's like you know yeah that's not
a drink in like eight months and you're
like Zach I saw him two weeks ago all
the mixer blasted out of his mind I got
well that's what I thought you know but
I'm just saying whether they're either
on again off again on again off again I
just I got blood clots and then you know
I told the doc I said I said Doug does
this mean I gotta like chill out on the
sauce he just goes well Zach I don't
mean to be debbie downer over here but
uh he goes let me ask something he goes
did you did your parents have this by
the way I know I wouldn't know I go
they're both up in God's tavern so I
can't I can't I can't tell you for sure
he goes and Barb was with me at the time
right you know you're mortal beloved and
she goes you're Zack as a doctor I don't
know how to say this but all your years
of drinking may have saved your life and
I go see drinking is good for something
you know but needless to say there was
no law there was no laughter from the
peanut gallery at that point but how did
save your life but no he just he just
told me he goes a key and I'm looking at
your your this one I was 42 because I'm
50 now so he just goes
I'm looking at your liver count and your
pancreas count he goes I'm telling you
right now Zach but the way you go
berserk and with the fellas and you the
way you tell me you drink every day he
is without a doubt you'll have to have a
liver transplant before you're 45 and he
goes I'm because I'm just looking at
numbers you know I mean cuz like on a
gas tank he goes you know with that
double dual you got over there if you're
driving from LA to Vegas on a quarter of
a tank again there's you won't make it
you just you just won't right so he goes
off he goes and then the pancreas he
goes guys he goes we're getting better
with the livers so you guys but it's
still a pain in the ass he goes or the
pancreas guys either die on that table
or they they could say goodbye to
everybody they know in about four days
and but they don't leave here and he
goes or door number three you can you
know fish yourself silly while you're
listening to Led to you Led Zeppelin
records and your Black Sabbath albums
and hang out with your wife and your
kids and your dogs and all your buddies
and I was like well I definitely love
Jimmy Page definitely love the fisting
aspect and definitely hanging out with
the wife and the kids and the dogs and
my buddy so I'll take door number three
so yeah that was the end of the line
that was it he told you how to stop and
that was there was no had the blood
clots form that I remember you were
wearing like those pantyhose or whatever
those tight things that kind of I still
wear them you know what you know you
know the the the you know like the sock
things you know I mean just to keep you
know the compression yeah yeah
compression socks but I mean not just I
got to take a blood thinner in the
morning then I take one before night you
know along with the uh you know the
Black Label viagra you know what I mean
so it's uh it's a daily routine does it
[ __ ] you up though because blood
thinners they say can mess up your
erections do that that's really scared
me is that you figured if it's thinning
your blood right exactly but no I had no
problems there man so you know that's
why I said between the the Valhalla Java
odinforce blend fortified with man woo
domination juice in there as well so uh
you take something balanced it out yeah
exactly you know like I said with the
White Castle and the Jenny Craig you
know what I mean it's a fine balancing
act did he actually say that uh the
drinking helps save you
well it obviously was thin in my blood
all those years right you know I mean
cuz that's what that's what booze is Wow
so but I mean but he but he was just
making a cracking a joke you know what I
mean yeah but I mean what it is though
it does kind of make sense though if I
mean if I did have it genetically for my
mom and dad you know what I mean
if I was predisposed with it obviously I
was basically taking blood thinners
since I went to ozzy osbourne University
that was the best cuz when I first
joined the band I were over in England
working on the record I've ever mom
Sharon calls up Barbara at time and you
know cuz I said she's been like my
mother since I've been 19 years old
since I joined a band right she calls up
barb and goes excuse me pop man justice
aqui have a drinking problem you know
cuz I would be the only one that would
hang out with the boss no no one would
hang out you know because everyone would
be obviously in fear of their job as
well you know because it's just like you
know as if your wife knows I'm hanging
out with you and I'm enabling father Jim
you know while we're drinking sauce you
know she's like who's getting Jim
drinking again it's like a whole sacks
hanging out with Jim all the time going
through the Irish pubs it's like then
I'm out of the picture you know what I
mean right
so no one would want to hang out with
you you know excuse me cuz Chan would
see them as a bad influence right I
doubt so here I am
remember bTW god bless his soul Preeti
was around with us since you known him
since the 70s and then when he started
with st. roads and you know started his
solo career I member BT when I was
rooming with him he goes aqui
Sagi don't get caught in the web stay
out of the web he's bringing you into
the web I was like La Paz I wanna hang
out with the boss you know I mean so did
you stop no he was just like yeah with
the gruesome twosome so I mean it was
just like no one would hang out would
have except for me yeah I mean so how
did you survive the wrath of Charon oh
ma I don't know it just I I you know I
was kind of she just let me hang around
when I mean I just like I guess she was
like well somebody's got a hang out with
him that's what I mean but uh I know it
was just like she call Barba she
the Zaki have a drinking problem she
goes oh no no no she goes well he does
now obviously two weeks with the boss
I've already just boozing it like it's
nobody's business but uh no just um yeah
you know I mean as far as with the
drinking though I mean it's just like
that was the end of the line I mean I
just always tell everybody it was a good
time man yeah a good run dude I want a
couple Super Bowls with her about this I
mean I had a Hall of Fame career
I'm not complaining you just move on to
the next phase now we're team owners
really the Tom Brady of alcoholism you
have a so you are and you guys you went
back with Ozzy for the first time in a
long time you guys just toured I didn't
see you guys but it was like now you're
both sober oh yeah you're both on the
road not drinking so is that any
different is the first time you guys
I've looked at me and I looked at him
and I go who are you he goes who are you
and what are we doing yet I mean do you
guys still like hang out socially or do
you both realize that if you're hanging
out socially you're both gonna want to
drink because that's what you did with
each other yeah now we just go to you
know like Caligula whorehouses for arts
and crafts without doing it if you do it
your whole life in like that's what you
do on the bus and that's what you do
before the show and after the show it's
like what do you do to fill the time now
that you're not doing that no I put it
this way I mean you know the way I
always look at it you know and you just
don't drink anymore because it's just
like I always tell you know so exact
would you want to go to like talk to
kids at rehabs or whatever I go yeah I
don't care I test like go but put it
this way but there's nothing really that
needs to be said it's just like good
have a good time all the time and then
once it starts getting a little silly
you just go and that's the end of that
you know I mean that's it it's like it
can't be that easy I go now it is I'll
show you how to play stairway to heaven
you gotta practice I don't know what
more to tell you so what's pretty much
yet I don't know you didn't have that
like you don't have to go through the 12
steps or do they know I do AAA and they
still go and I liked it I thought I'd be
needed I just had my buddies there and I
have friends there and we just go and
have a good time you know and then we go
to a Caligula brothel one who just said
have a blast but I mean but the whole
thing is I know I mean my whole thing is
you know I remember one day when I first
you know when we first stopped drinking
or whatever I may be but you know any of
the fellas but it was just like I'll
make sure there's no booze in his hotel
room or there's no booze on the side I
go listen if I find out who ended up
taking booze out of my mini-fridge
because they think I'm a weak-willed
candy-ass I will bash your brains in a
bunch I find out who did it so I said I
suggest if you don't like ending up in
the ICU for about several - you know
months at a clip I suggest you keep the
sauce in the mini-fridge cuz I mean now
now it's a now you're it's a question of
my manhood at that point you know I'm
sorry you took it as a challenge almost
well yeah you just like go you know I
mean you're gonna let it beat you or
you're gonna you know if you don't like
losing then you ain't gonna lose right
so you know you you just go it's no
problem but I don't wake up I don't wake
up like jonesing for a cocktail or
anything like that the Caligula brothels
definitely but I mean me be the booze
now it's just that that was Tuesday
today's Wednesday all right what time we
on stage let's go do this that's the way
I've always looked at it right I mean
it's just like you know we're pitching
or whatever we're in a game I'm Bob Jim
I'm your catcher you give up a home run
in Game seven of the World Series we're
in the first inning and you can sit
around walking around with your head
down kicking the dirt I'm like I just
walk out to the mound I go first off
don't ever ever put your head down ever
and then second off we got like eight
more innings to go bro
I go and we'll get the runs back so
don't worry about it
that just happened actually who cares
can you get the rest of these guys out I
mean that's a you just have to see you
don't dwell like you're not a guy who
dwells I don't know do your [ __ ] move on
to the next yeah yeah that was Tuesday
today Wednesday let's go that's a pretty
practical and good night to have him you
don't get caught up and let's say you
and your wife fight you have an argument
about something are you are you good at
going
apologizing or if she apologizes you go
to go alright we're done definitely even
during the boozing days you know I mean
it's just like if we if something got a
little silly I'd be the first one to say
I'm sorry and stuff like that so you
know yeah just get it over wooden and
forget about you I want on anything it's
like water to a dock man you just gotta
you know just say you're sorry and then
let's get moving here man
you don't harp you don't harp on
mistakes that she's big you'll all right
yeah I want to carry that garbage around
I carry that weight around man
it sucks cuz the minute you say you're
sorry and you know what you really are
anyway so you know and then just move on
so do you think you got it and then you
can get back to the fondling your
virginity yeah anyways you realize from
a young age like there's a lot of fun
[ __ ] to do in life
like if you're 19 and you're playing
with Ozzie like you're like the life can
be a lot of fun I'm not gonna dwell on
anything except for the great stuff that
is right here in front of me yeah and I
think it's all I think it's all
perception too you know like even when
we had when we were drinking if you only
had half a beer left I didn't look at as
a half as the glass is half-empty it's
just like it's half-full and if we drink
it fast enough for cop a decent buzz you
see what I'm saying it's just perception
we still got half a beer right you've
got halfway there instead of gold man
what a bummer we only got half a beers
like no if you look at it on the other
side right it is still half up here and
if we drink it fast enough we can use
this or it's good if you look at it from
the other side you can still get a
little buzz going well yeah just look at
Captain America in the Super Bowl last
year it's just like well we're getting
crushed right now it's like yeah but we
still got 30 minutes to come back and
win this thing right so there you go
that's it I've never seen all the years
I've been talking to you or known you
I've never seen you anything other than
this I've never seen you angry um you
know even backstage I've never seen you
[ __ ] at anybody you always seem to be
very even-keeled and upbeat and well I'm
in definitely I mean in the past but you
know when you're when you look at
yourself when you get pissed off about
things or whatever when you go yeah I
mean well it's almost kind of like high
school stuff where you go I can't
believe like I even got bummed out about
that you know what I mean or whatever or
like Julie Thompson breaking up with you
you know and you go
think man be like like really and I go
well she did have some pretty slammin
gazongas get a chance to fondle them at
the Caligula whorehouse yeah so uh no
but you you really think about it man I
mean it's just like next you know I mean
you get into fights when you were in
high school um because it seems like
this attitude would lead you to not
getting in why you still got no argument
cuz some guys would just be like look at
your fishnets they don't even match your
high heel Frank you know I mean things
like that I get into arguments over that
sure alright wait a minute are these
pressurized socks that you're wearing or
they actually full or they go all the
way up how high they go these things um
I usually wear them straight till it
goes to the other testicles to keep me
hold helm on so I can actually hold out
for longer than the six minute black
label love barrier that's off not a
complete embarrassment
thanks promoting uh gimme hits the two
new Black Label Society album it's out
January the 19th so you have a little
outfits Oh grim is the sorry I said
gimme the companies like are there any
hits I go I got grim news no so now you
already know going in
you are you you like I wanted to make a
Greatest Hits you have to have hits
right right we don't have any right
there's we prefer to keep the band the
people's band and not sell out you see
because this way you don't have any hit
songs you're still true to the music
well that's the way were you like that
at all
man you are one of my favorite things
that you've ever done is the film rock
star I can't tell you I'm not being
sarcastic I'm not I that is like I don't
know what it is about that thing I watch
it probably at least six times a year I
think I think father Mark Wahlberg and
sister Jen over there when they signed
up for this movie they were like
and what did I sign up for here part of
you feel I go like how did this movie
get made
I have no idea either all I know is when
they they ask me to do it they go but
what is it you want me to do they go
well you can basically just play guitar
all day and then we'll have you shooting
a gun at some point you know on a thing
and then drinking booze I go and you're
gonna pay me for this okay yeah no but I
mean it was it was a great time making
that thing I mean mark super cool Jen
super cool I'm everybody but everybody
on that movie was and I'm buddies but
you know all the guys that weren't
abandoned I mean like that so I mean it
was just like a massive summer camp for
the whole time we were making a movie it
really is awesome do you have to you'd
they they made you shave for that movie
though right yeah every day I had to
shave man so and then what happened was
at the end of the movie which never
ended up in the movie there was a thing
of where are they now so they did of
like when the band broke up and the band
was no longer or whatever and I had a
thing where I basically had a beard on
and I ended up like I wasn't in music
anymore I just lived in the woods
somewhere and I was just like hunting my
own food and stuff like that and I just
had a big beard and I was like I
remember when we had to put the thing on
every day I would go dude I think I'm
gonna grow a beard when I get done with
this movie you know cuz I had to shave
every day and stuff like that yeah why
it was at that point I said I want to
look this ridiculous do you like it
yeah so that was about it so I mean it
was after rockstar that you were like
I'm just never shaving again yeah so and
you ought to see the genitalia and yes
the wife it takes her about it's a
production it takes about a half an hour
to get in there you know what I mean so
that's house of horrors and she's locked
in was there any point that like
Jennifer Aniston was gone like dude what
are we doing here with I think the whole
entire movie is like friends to this Wow
I must not like myself too much is that
was the first like Jennifer Aniston at
the time that movie came out I was like
friends was the biggest had been the
biggest show on TV and he was like yeah
but she's a movie star - and it's like
to a certain audience liked the movie
rockstar is like it's kind of like the
Judas Priest story I think they must
have drugged mark and
juhee and then it was like the movie was
over and they were like and they were at
the premiere going what did i do I was
in this no but uh like I said I mean it
was yeah I I thought I mean it was a
good time and I mean the more the movies
like could piss a lot of funny stuff in
a movie so I mean if you watched it back
actually I mean it's like amazing I mean
it's just like I see it a lot of times
either on airplanes yeah it's on all the
time yeah and then you'll see it on like
you know TBS or you know you see it like
you know the the Sunday morning movie or
whatever it is but you know yeah it's
pretty funny it's like this little cult
thing now so I'm [ __ ] awesome but I
yeah we've run into people all the time
they're like through that movies like
hysterical so have you seen it Jim I
have but it's like in bits and pieces
I've never seen the entire thing all the
way good for you kid just bits and
pieces I've seen here and there I've
never watched the entire thing that's in
between final fondling the man just
blasting away no it's just a little line
to get back sometimes I'll stop edging
turn on a film from like Caligula no
yeah it's a great film without a doubt
the great fella very caring very giving
guy you know you won't ever want to have
a good time basically he really didn't
know how to throw a party not a good one
yet not even gonna know he wasn't one
for tradition no he was not yeah play
wanted to bless them Caesars it all hang
out well you know they shot the hardcore
sex stuff in that at night so the actors
in that movie had no idea what they were
doing like yeah you know uh they were in
rockstar they really didn't know they
Malcom McDowel John Gielgud I just did
they're doing this film about ancient
Roman he's filming these hardcore [ __ ]
scenes after they leave and they had no
idea that there was hardcore pornography
mixed it yeah great it's an Ozzy
after-show party you got a few that
Jennifer Aniston was surprised to the
premiere of rock star imagine Malcolm
McDowell showing up the Carrera Caligula
like wow yeah there's a guy blowing
another guy back there because if they
do like all that all the sex scenes and
stuff in the night yes they did them
when it when the actors were not there
so they would walk through a particular
orgy scene and you know to be shot like
a raid in our movie and then Gucci
owning those guys would shoot
hardcore sex it came out great but
there's a VAR version and then there's
the X version the X version is really
erotic yeah it's basically a porno movie
with movie stars yeah yeah that's the
one that we don't show to the eighth
graders you know when they want to show
them about Rome yeah in the Roman
history class we stick with the r-rated
Caligula but that's funny the motion I
would say that's probably the most
accurate look at when a Roman dictator
was like like they had Tiberius Caesar
played by Peter O'Toole he was like into
like little kids and [ __ ] and with
the way Caligula tied off that guy's
dick and fed him wine and stuck a sword
numb I got about another good times do
you ever get worried with all the sexual
misconduct allegations being thrown
around these days do you get worried
that like groupies from the past or any
of the old school rock days are gonna
come back to haunt you well I remember a
couple incidents you know with odd
however early the Animal House years a
black label I remember these two girls
were in the sub at the time I guess they
were hanging out with some of the guys
either in a band or in a doom crew
Incorporated so uh but I was in there
just hanging out in the sub it was after
that after the big rock show and uh I
was like eh girls I do can I get you
guys something to drink or whatever
they're like no no okay no we're all
giggling and stuff I was like I was like
what the guy what's so funny cuz I was
bending over getting some of the tray I
was like I figured my pants busted open
there's not my dad she goes no but you
know we used to have posted to you back
in the day you know with the big poufy
hair when I was when I first started
with the boss with uh so it was just
like I go oh yeah I go I go that's
probably the last time my wife actually
wanted to actually sleep with me you
know I mean she goes I cuz I'm out on
the couch and they they just go honey
we're all giggling some more they go I
go I said what's up buddy oh man you
know we'd you know we'd do to you and
I'm waiting to hear like some Caligula
gothel's know if you know what I mean
and some good time stuff so some stories
I could tell Bob about her you know say
you know these two two hot chicks were
on the sub and they wanted to do this to
me so maybe you could try it yeah but
they they were just like I was like what
would you do and I go we think you have
such a hot ass we'd love to put strap-on
zone and just blast you up yes and I
just go well now you know why I don't
cheat on my wife
and I remember there's one other time I
remember with the boss I think we first
of all can I just say that that's my
dream scenario you just mentioned that's
another good time out you know what I
mean but I just want to make sure you
don't eat a heavy meal before that right
I don't you don't want to get a big
steak house after that one with the
fellas you know but uh but the whole
thing is and if you do just maybe just
get the fish you know but where's the
other time with I remember with Oz we
were hanging out and odd I think we did
like McNichols arena or something like
that time member we're gonna we're in a
steam shower I had that thing going on
oz is sitting down I'm sitting down the
steam was like kicking in and we're just
like chilling out I'm just talking to
just relaxing nauseas these two girls
actually came into the shower and they
saw sitting there like oh sorry and then
they left right and then oz looks at me
and I look at him he goes zurk you know
what those girls just thought and I said
what's at us yeah she they both took one
quick look at my dick and they just said
look at that thing I guess I'll put it
behind my ears smoke now with
opportunities like that now like your
high school sweetheart Kimmy I've known
my wife since sixth grade
yeah and then we went to go see the
urban cowboy movie Travolta into that
yep and she wouldn't let me uh I got the
I got the lockdown I wouldn't I went to
go up her shirt and I got the I got shut
down and she wouldn't let me pass the
red you know the red rope there into
studio 54 and I uh I dropped her like a
bad habit on Monday and then after that
so when we started high school I
remember she went with the the gym
teachers son he was a year older than us
Rick Keller and I member ah so she went
with him for about three years and then
I remember like when we had the band
going yeah
Rick would be like hey barn you know
Zak's got his band together let's go see
him you know we'd be playing you know
Fozzie we'd be playing you know whatever
cream Rosh Hendrix
you know Sabbath and somebody that she
goes to let's go see him they're playing
it like Ketchum's kitchen tonight or you
know we'd planted some keg parties you
go now he's an [ __ ]
I wouldn't go to anything by him so she
still says that a lot but I mean but the
whole thing is uh senior year of high
school we had the same class I think
like business class or something like
that so but I remember like hanging out
at all time cheating off or tehsil time
then we started hanging out and then
since that day forward I've had no
problems getting past the red rope and
interstates later that's amazing to me
they're like late and they telling us
that zach has to wrap up it's amazing to
me that like all of a sudden the girl
doesn't like you and she's like [ __ ] am
I don't want to see him it's like you
never know like you speak you someone
isn't into you at one point does it mean
like exactly I mean do you ever get
jealous you know what barb with her past
boyfriends or anything you know she went
with this would kill a guy and brick is
married now and has it with her best
friend and all this other stuff is
hysterical but I mean but the whole
thing is yes she was with Rick for three
years and I'm like no not at all I said
I think it's awesome I go every time
she's destroying me and fondling the man
room and pounding on the genitalia
Oh doom I just go thank you Rick Keller
and strain and she's like amazing I have
nothing but great things to say so you
promised me tricks earlier work without
a doubt he's amazing and I thank him and
I write him thank-you letters all the
time faster he's always amazing